hey everyone eric voss here in the blue
dungeon and watching the emmys tonight
there is a new
trailer for one division on disney plus
marvel's upcoming series sometime in
2020 that goes into the mind of the
scarlet witch wanda maximoff after
losing her beloved vision in infinity
war and still
not getting them back in in-game because
i guess it didn't matter that much
but now the two are getting their day in
this crazy reality
channel switching show i'm so glad we
have new marvel stuff to talk about
finally i'm just gonna give you my
raw reaction to this i have another
video coming out soon that's going to
break down my plot theory for this
and then on tuesday we're going to get
our frame by frame breakdown of all the
visual clues that you missed but in
terms of reaction here
we go
[Music]
this is our home now i want us to fit in
oh this is going to be a gas where did
you two move from
how long have you been married and why
don't you have children yet
our story i think what my wife means to
say is that we go
move from where married when damn it why
oh are they're stopping stop it's dark
stop it
oh this looks great
[Music]
am i dead no why would you think that
because you are
oh that laugh classic
ah we are an initial couple you know
oh i don't think that was ever in
question
[Music]
oh yes oh marvelous
forgive me uh i'm very excited it's rare
that we have new pieces of marvel
content to talk about these days
okay so uh the marvel cinematic universe
hasn't gone into
the psychology of wanda maximoff a whole
lot but yes she is a scarlet witch and
yes she has the power to reset reality
something that has been explored
fascinatingly in comic series like house
of m and it looks like the visual
template that they're using
in this show is by exploring different
sitcom tropes and sitcom formats
throughout the ages
we see the classic black and white 50s
thing and notice there was this
shifting aspect ratio it started in this
really old school letterbox with the
curved edges and it just widened and
widened out
as her perspective was widening out to
reality they had that fun thing where
she's like
wait i uh our origin story is uh is uh
it's like an inception where they're
like how did you get here and they're
like
uh we just came from the uh uh and just
like how inception was dealing with that
idea of you don't really know your
reality ever truly objectively
that's what they're exploring in wanda
vision and it looks very exciting now
there's been a lot of theories about
catherine han's character being agatha
harkness she is a witch a sorceress who
serves mephisto in the comics and this
trailer almost confirms that's who she's
playing
there's some kind of halloween episode
where they're all wearing their classic
costumes
wanda it's dressed up in the comic book
version of the scarlet witch vision is
wearing the the green and yellow costume
that he wears in the comics
catherine hans character is dressed up
as a witch here with that great great
cackle
we also see a shot where she's doing her
little hand dance poor elizabeth olsen
in the past films she's like yeah joss
whedon just told me to just do this with
my hands and that's
my power but now they're actually giving
it a physical effect on the world when
she does that the tv set rearranges
around her the music we're hearing is uh
twilight time by the platters it was
like an old 50s
crooner song i'm gonna dig into all the
lyrics and what they could mean for
actual like plot implications and the
full
in-depth breakdown that we're gonna do
we also get a very quick look of tiona
paris as monica rambo the adult version
of the little girl who is in captain
marvel
in the marvel comics her character name
is spectrum or photon and by the look of
it she's being sucked into this reality
kind of coming through this membrane
that looks like a tv screen a tv channel
so even though we're seeing some
familiar sitcom tropes there's some
homages to full house it looks like
maybe bewitch maybe roseanne really i
think there's a much much darker
plot that is behind the illusory sitcom
realities that we're seeing
one that involves wanda desperately
trying to resurrect her beloved vision
using actual witchcraft which is very
cool and in the next video on this
channel i'm gonna go into the whole
lore of the marvel spell book called the
dark hold and how this series could set
up one of maximoff as the villain of
doctor strange ii coming out
sometime in the future again there's a
lot to unpack here we're gonna be
talking about this a lot on the channel
this week so be sure to subscribe to new
rockstars if you aren't already hit that
notification bell so you'll get all of
our videos the moment they come out
follow me on instagram at eavos follow
new rockstars on all socials
guys marvel is still alive vision isn't
but marvel is
see you soon bye
[Music]
you